John Durham bosses got a deck of cards
and he's on his knees on the Rich Eisen
show Callaway corner trying to flip
cards into the Hall this is amazing
you're coming close John as soon as they
said what we do baby atta boy
keep rolling them in John doar emboss
America's Got premieres January 7th on
NBC just okay be quiet
John Dornbos for birdie flipping cards
into holes Oh close
all right that's next year on the Rich
Eisen show welcome back John Doyle
awesome and I'm so excited to be here
I'm a fan right back and I told you this
the first time I met you you have one of
the greatest logos ever cuz you know cuz
it's it's uh
it's a silky-smooth style so good to see
you so you have a deck of cards and I'm
gonna make this super easy just say the
word stop stop okay
whatever this card is you got it yo can
you see it yeah we can it doesn't matter
if I see it qinger close I'm just gonna
rip off the corner watch okay you hold
the card I shall hold I got the corner
watch the corner okay that's when the
corner goes underneath the checks makes
there's what do you see there a box I
see a box yeah yeah move the chex mix
and then and then look look
shake the box is there something inside
the box there is something inside that's
open the box there's a corner to one
card check it out
that corner fits perfect now what butBut
now you know what to expect so watch
this oh oh you gonna do is this are you
ready pull it out pull a different card
out it doesn't matter and then hold it
in front of the camera and then I want
you to take it and actually rip that
card in half hamburger or hotdog style
it doesn't really matter okay and then
put the pieces on top and rip those in
half again yeah yeah oh this is perfect
you were killing so what do we got here
we got a ten of Hearts this we do hold
the corner I'm gonna take these pieces
and fold these pieces up so we got three
pieces of Atena hearts and all you got
to do is this let me see your hand
that's when the pieces disappear now
since then earlier we had a refit inside
the Chex Mix
come on now open the checks bags and
dump them out on your desk I know it's
gonna make a mess but dump them out on
your desk get dump them all out not only
they're three pieces of a carbon side
come on that card is back in one that
card back in one baby it's missing one
corner you rip the corner it fits
perfect and that when you want to eat
just have it on his desk I'm gonna boss
everybody and you've checked the base-10
our hearts that's a mechanic's clubs oh
my gosh
and a jack-of-all-trades and I got Chex
Mix fantastic John Dornbos when we come
back that is amazing all right welcome
back to the Rich Eisen show and we just
got an amazing first close-up glimpse of
this man's magic literally and
figuratively America's Got Talent the
championship premieres again January 7th
on NBC airs Mondays at 8:00 p.m. Eastern
Time part of that program and back on
this program John Dornbos good to see
you wow man again thank you for having
me big help come on right right back at
this is like the first show to do before
we get into before yeah take a nice
little swig of the Rich Eisen show mug
so before we get into the current
situation your heart I want to get into
this here so you've been living with a
problem in your heart all the way up
until you got traded from the Eagles to
the Saints walk me through yeah so I
never knew yeah I never knew I had a
congenital heart defect and to put
layman's terms you have a heart and you
have a vein that leaves the heart and
that veins called an aorta and it goes
up and around and down yeah and when the
blood leaves the heart the door opens
and closes so that the blood can leave
and not fall back in yeah that door for
most people is three leaflets right most
people have three little doors that
close I was born with two and so over
time my my door would like fall into
itself so picture of French doors that
never seal and never shut so air goes in
and out of your house that's a problem
yeah it's problem so my blood would
leave the heart
but almost 60% of it would fall back
into the heart right so I was losing a
lot of blood and multiple things happen
there
one the heart's a muscle and so if your
brain is is the the boss and your heart
is the employee the brain wants let's
say five six quarts of blood a minute
five and half quarts of blood a minute I
believe well your heart can calculate
that so obviously a lot of my blood was
going back into my heart so the heart is
like okay I need to pump harder because
only 40 percents leaving so it
calculates to where it gets the the
brain five quarts of blood so it's a
muscle so now my resting heart rate was
always really really high and I just
thought that was normal
well now it's a muscle so now it's
working to our now it grows so cheating
my heart got way too big and like a pair
of sweatpants if you pull the waist you
lose the elasticity of course snap back
so when did you find out you had this
issue and yeah so I got traded in New
Orleans and for whatever reason I had
heard people say the term heart murmur
but I didn't know what it meant
right so-and-so has a heart murmur or
you read about it so a heart murmur is
basically blood leaking somewhere it
shouldn't and when you put a stethoscope
on your back it's a drum
it's the heart it's like it's a drum
well if you hear a squish sound like
that is the leaking blood and so for
whatever reason when I went into New
Orleans and had my physical it was
prevalent at that time and literally I
got lucky and the doctor was like hey I
hear a murmur and it's it's in kind of a
unique place we're gonna send you down
to the hospital and do further testing
all right let's go I don't think I know
it but that's what I found out and then
they told you what so I go down to the
hospital I do an echocardiogram and some
other stuff and the the cardiologist and
surgeon said all right yeah go back
we'll get your results ASAP and I was
getting ready for practice and my phone
rang and it was a New Orleans area code
so I figured it was the hospital right
nobody else had my number out there so I
answered it and the surgeon and
cardiologist said hey look I don't know
how to say this so are you sitting down
I said yeah yeah what's up and you're
still oblivious right I'm going to
practice right you're never playing
football over again and I literally just
went wait what like I'm I just signed a
three-year extension you're going to
practice I'm gonna practice and you're
gonna be an emergency open heart surgery
now
wait what go to the trainer's room and
we're we got all the details we're gonna
bring you back for further testing
you're okay but no
Thayne no running no lifting anything
over 5 pounds don't raise your voice
don't do this don't do that don't ya
so basically sit there and keep your
heart rate down and I was like what the
heck is going on and then you get the
information and you go from there so
what kept you calm anything keep you
calm um uncertainty I guess
all right if you say be calm then I
guess that's what I'm gonna do because
this is your lane right right so this
guy knows what he's talking about and
then all of a sudden I called my I
wanted to Sean Payton's office who coach
Payton is unbelievable and my wife had
just got went from New Orleans back to
Philly to coordinate the move yeah right
and I said hey do I call my wife or what
do I do or do I wait and he goes I let's
call her and now we call her
Sean Payton suggested yeah let's call
its call your wife tell her what we know
and let's get her back here to New
Orleans and let's figure this out I said
cool him down and now believe it or not
I remember what coach Reed said and I
got to play for Coach Reed for a long
time still talk to him still look up to
him I'm thankful for every every second
I got to spend with him and I remember
we lost a game and he said he was
talking to somebody else but he said hey
if the captain keeps his cool the ship
keeps his cool
if the captain loses his cool the ship
loses their cool keep your cool and I
was like okay hey babe our friends and
family nobody knows what's going on but
us if we keep our cool the ship keeps
their cool if we lose our cool our ships
gonna lose their cool so guess what you
and I we're keeping our cool and we
ain't dying we're gonna live we're gonna
tackle this thing just like we would
anything else and we're gonna come out
the other side and let's do this and
that's what happened that's what
happened and now as any we would say the
Tom's yours yeah well thank God right
yeah I mean that you got traded do you
think that the trade do you sit here
John darn boss and think that that trade
saved your life absolutely I mean
absolutely and well it doesn't matter
what religion you are it doesn't matter
what you practice but there's a certain
kind of romantic
sign of life to say that I was traded to
New Orleans to be saved by Saint and
well that's what happened and so I never
wanted a dog I never wanted a dog I love
dogs I don't want one you open the door
they run I just don't talk okay
so my wife wants one every day quit
we're talking like yeah yeah so sure
enough I'm on 21 pills and I'm just
sitting there staring at a wall right
post surgery and she puts a laptop on me
and she says hey we should get a dog and
it's a goldendoodle rights accused dog
never seen mm I'm on 21 pills right sure
you want a dog no I don't want a dog
what that dog right there I want to put
him on bed and she's like okay so the
next day this guy showed up and we got
the coolest dog ever and I said we'll
get this dog hmm
but it's gonna be a reminder of how
happy you are to be alive so as long as
we can name him Saint then we're gonna
get him and so sure enough our dog's
name is Saint Saens cool come on great
dog named ed it is a great dog name and
obviously an incredible story as to how
the dog got his name right okay
that's that's amazing and did the Eagles
is it true the Eagles gave you a Super
Bowl ring did that happen yeah really
cool you know Jeff and I when I first
signed with Philly I don't know if Jeff
flurry realizes this but in Lehigh
Valley in Pennsylvania is really hot and
so me and the punter and kicker we would
always try to find reasons to go back
inside to get on the Oconee sugar
practice because we weren't doing
nothing right so I had to go to the
bathroom a lot during training camp
right cuz I give and go to the air
conditioner I maybe sneak a chicken
finger so I went in there and there's
Jeff flurry so now I gotta act like I
was supposed to go back there for
something right so I go in the equipment
room and now I'm looking for something
like I just don't know what I'm looking
for but I'm like yeah Jeff I just gotta
try and find something so then him and I
just start talking and I remember
telling him hey you know unless the
Super Bowl got brought up in coaching
and I was like yeah I never want to be a
coach but I think the only way I'll get
a ring is as a player because you know
that's no I don't want a coach so sure
enough years and years go by and this
whole thing goes down and Donnie Jones
went to Doug Peterson and said hey we're
taking Dornbos and Doug said heck yeah
we are Jeff said yeah we are so they
called me and said hey if we go you know
now I was on so many pillows I didn't
watch football that year and it wasn't
because I didn't want to it's just I was
literally in a fog and the first game I
watched was the NSU championship so
you're and it was at the beginning of
that playing season where you found out
about anywhere you had your heart
surgery correct yep all right and so you
had not seen anything of the Eagles
season I hadn't seen any of anything
except this white wall in front of me
like because I would just stare at it
right for months cuz you're on all these
meds and the irony is you know
Oh whoo we watch it and my wife goes
John the Eagles are going to the
Superbowl and I said of course they are
after the Superbowl they signed me and I
played in a hundred and sixty-two
straight games for the franchise record
for most consecutive games ever played
right and then they got rid of me and
now they're going back I'm like of
course they're going to the Super Bowl
why wouldn't they the key was to get rid
of me and that was the joke but then
sure enough yeah Jeff called and said
hey man you were part of this
organization in the culture and you're
not gonna get a ring you'll get a
player's ring just like everybody else
and what that mean to you you know what
I I never thought I'd get one unless I
played and Jeff reminded me of that
conversation and I'm gonna get choked up
and he uh he said you didn't play but he
didn't coach either but you deserve this
and he gave me a hug and he said for the
the 12 years 11 years that you spent
here and you know spending time with his
family and just he said you showed up
every day hurt sick and injured and
you're a true Pro and so this ring here
is the Super Bowl for you was was life
and I hope you look at this ring and
reflect back on what you did in your
career and I hope you take what you
learned and what you did and apply it to
other aspects of your life and just look
at this and remember how hard it is to
have success and how great it is so keep
working hard and I just was like man
this is I'm not gonna say no I know you
know I mean I could see your your your
eyes are glistening up a little John
Doerr loss right now it's pretty cool
see you were part of the parade as well
did ya there yeah and you know there is
a lot of there was a debate right
there's a lot of people saying oh John
doesn't deserve when he was trailing
scum well you get those people right
which is fine because I get that because
any tray any player gets traded it
you're done and I teammates knew your
organ is the organization yeah and I get
d'Armes I mean so but what's cool for me
to look back on like my life story is
you know sometimes it doesn't matter how
you get there right and for me it was a
reminder that if you just show up every
day you just show up and you're on time
and you're ready you'll be amazed at
what happens and you'll never know what
happens but you're never gonna know
unless you show up and that's been my
motto just show up every day and you
know what the things that you want the
energies that you throw out there the
things that you want to spire in life
both materialistically spiritually
energy
why's happiness just tell yourself pick
the narrative that you want to have
happen and treat people right along the
way and guess what you it might happen
to you in a way that you never saw
coming
and that's what that ring did well John
darn boss here in the Rich Eisen show if
I'm not mistaken Chris Brockman your
first magic trick however was was I know
where this ago long snapping when you
really hadn't had much long snapping
experience and trying to pull off that
trick yeah John pretty good one would
you care to retell that story right here
all right so here here's the deal
I thought I was pretty good high school
player right led the league in tackles
didn't even make all League right now
come on to you that was devastated so
all right it's time to go to a junior
college in it's baseball football and
and be honest with you all I wanted to
do is run out of a tunnel in front of a
hundred thousand people I want to be a
rock star but I can't sing can't dance
and I can't play nice right but I still
want to go out of the tunnel one feel it
why not
so football was the key now Cerritos
Long Beach because I grew up in Garden
Grove here and so there's a lot of
number one JC conference in America well
then there's a school called Golden West
junior college and they were Owen twenty
I had a buddy that played there and is
is exactly what I said to myself if I
can't play there mmm I can't play anyway
so I went to where I knew I was gonna
play and I knew I'd be on the field and
I'd be on the field a lot cuz I knew
that if I want to go to a college you
can't make it can't get a scholarship
sitting on the bench right so sure
enough I go play I do really well
I'm academically qualified so I could
transfer out as a true freshman but
nothing so I was like what the heck so
oh man
Tim Thurmond yeah six six long snapper
hey it's pretty good better than than I
ever was so I took some of his film and
I just put on my highlight to him back
then no internet no HD so as long as
we're all white dudes like who can tell
the difference right so then Nick Heinle
I was number 47 he was number 48 and
this dude to this day I avoided hitting
him every time in practice I was the guy
and I was a good player but I avoided
hitting him and I never once went
head-to-head with him in practice and
nor did I ever want to he just knock
people out so it's like what we rotated
just take some of his big hits and I'll
just throw him on there too so it's like
me like finesse open-field making smart
plays covering slot receivers as a
backer it's Nick knocking people out
look it's you and then it's a six six
long snapper that's just throwing darts
I mean honestly if you saw this tape I
was the greatest player in the history
and and it's JUCO footage there's only
one camera right sure who's the wiser
and I do not remember - I gotta find
this tape I didn't have all the digital
stuff so like it was play pod recorders
play part of course and some of the
footage yeah I actually shot with like
the camera with the VHS tape and I would
put my finger and point on the screen I
would record the TV the plane the VHS
and just point to the guy that I was
saying was me right it's so bad so
anyways I had a snap since high school
and UTEP needed a snapper right a buddy
play there he vouched for me he knew the
other guys too so he called me up he's
like this is Tim coming here this is
true and I go no no just give me in the
door I'll ball out I promise just get me
in the door and it got me in the door
and I got a full ride and back then it
was when teams were just coming out with
a roster spot for a snapper so I was
kind of like the beginning of the era of
that becoming its own position rock on
baby for position I'd never should have
played America's Got Talent the
championship premieres January 7th on
NBC airs Mondays at 8:00 Eastern 7
central how's your life changed since
been on a GT man big time you know it's
uh I can relate this way buddy mine was
on an elevator with Joe Montana and
Roger Staubach right he's a real estate
guy right sure yeah oh yeah so this guy
gets in the elevator and goes oh my gosh
you're Joe Montana good grace football
player the quarterback ever oh my gosh
you're stuffy you're the Karina's real
estate guru so the guy gets off the
elevator and I guess Montana was like so
you know how did that feel that you
kinda everybody was like I mean how'd
that feel
mm and Raj goes perfect because when I
was done playing I was done I guess my
rebranding worked because now I'm a real
estate guy mm-hmm and so for me my
football career is over
and it was about rebranding and and
getting a name and a talent somewhere
else and starting a new life right for
my mind man that show worked and now
people I booked theaters and people show
up which is awesome I'm on your show and
it's cool it's cool to be able to show
the world what my interpretation of
magic is that it can be fun and it can
just be cool
and so yeah so what is your interpreted
and incredible trick that we're gonna
put on our our app and all of our social
media feeds with
that I know for years you and locker
rooms people like do let's do that I
mean Aaron Rodgers reaction to the Pro
Bowl are you doing something in a locker
room it's just still priceless to watch
so what do what do you what do you get
out of it and what is you know I think
it's finding who you are right though
I'm a huge David Copperfield fan and I
love them but the world doesn't need a
David Copperfield they don't need
another one
david blank retains all these guys and
all of a sudden I did a GT and I found
out that you know what I like inspiring
I like telling my story yeah and so I
kind of gear the magic in the story to
that so my live show that we tour with
is basically my life story and it's
literally the magic I learned along the
way that helped me get through a time in
my life to find happiness and I try and
make it as rockstar and upbeat as
possible I hit on real issues and you
know a simple trick is you sign a card
you tear it up piece by piece well that
can be symbolic in so many different
ways and and you know Lance Burton was a
famous magician in Vegas that you're the
hardest the hardest thing to do is to
get people to care you know you do a
dove act and what's the golfclap because
are they emotionally tied to the act
right but when they get tied to it man
and I remember I was doing a corporate
speaking gig you know for in Corpus
Christi Texas
ten thousand people at the American Bank
Center whatever it is in the stage hand
goes [ __ ] ten bucks you can't get a
stand ovation
making a coin disappear I said it's home
baby and that's when I realized all I
got to do is get these people to care
about this coin right and sure enough I
built it up I made the coin disappear
and the place went nuts
hmm and that's when I realized that just
tie your emotion to a be vulnerable be
real right and then the magic will take
care of itself and it'll tie everything
together perfectly so and then I joined
Allen which was amazing and her crew and
we believe in the same thing man just be
kind and have fun and do your thing and
show the world who you are and with that
comes great responsibility so be careful
what you say start I know I keep
rambling here but my star is a star is
born' amazing movie but there's a line
that on it's just like man there's
there's like one-liners and like
gladiator stars born that just hit you
and it's when Bradley Cooper says hey
you got a voice but they're only gonna
listen for so long so you better be
careful on what you say and how you want
to say it because that's all that
matters
ton of people can sing but it's what you
have to say well the same thing is on
your show and as a magician as a speaker
as a person in life be careful what you
say because those words are gonna affect
people and those words are gonna be what
your reality becomes and so I believe in
that no that's contagious man just sit
next year fear actually can I get that
back in an audio clip cuz I think I need
to write down I don't mean to sound like
that guy but like you can sound I've
been trying to put that into words for a
long time and you stuck the land man ten
out of ten and you know what do you
think your your old teammates in Philly
gonna run it back right now it sure
looks like it man I'll tell you what I
mean Philly's lucky to have both Carson
n foals you know I mean those are I got
to play with both they love Doug
Peterson they still got Jason Peters in
the locker room is a huge leader and
Darren Sproles Malcolm
I love the center I love call Jason
Kelsey's unbelievable that dude's one of
the greatest human beings the first long
is I mean awesome Jenkins I love I mean
there's some real human being chris is
cool man and super nice Malcolm and you
know Fletcher Fletcher I mean I got to
play with a lot of cool people who did
but you know going back to it I think a
huge just strictly tactical right let's
just talk football you wonder you X's
and O's John I think some of the some of
the times that teams have a problem is
your starter and your backup are so
different
athletically and scheme wise so if one
goes down you're thrown in a whole new
world right right and then all of a
sudden the talent shift so hey we got to
move you here you go here when this
guy's in you go here that's like
everybody's out of position right well
when Nick or Carson go down or they
switch it's the same game so your old
linemen are basically blocking for the
same guy you know you can argue Carson's
a little bit faster but that's
irrelevant you know they're both tall
big they're both students of the game
they're both throwing quarterbacks and
so I think just that alone from a
chemistry standpoint right in the
receivers that are running it's the same
look right they got a real tall big guy
back there right and it's it's just the
same look so I think all that plays a
huge huge deal in success it does seem
that foals at least this year for sure
has had a better command of anybody
outside the numbers than Carson did
before before he got hurt I mean your
Super Bowl MVP right I know I know but
by the way what you just said about how
it helps the Eagles to have similar
style as well as physical yet people at
quarterback that's what I think has made
what the Ravens did this year so
impressive to go from flat coat to Lamar
Jackson you know obviously they had
someplace for tomorrow
built-in and then for that by week
they've they've totally recast
themselves yeah and some people can do
it and some people struggle and now here
come the Saints to the one seed yeah I'm
not gonna put you in that position
you know what if they do face each other
man how cool would that have been to
play in that game that'll be your
greatest magic trick is to not choose a
sign on why I guess I'm a winner in but
either case look at you you damn
straight it's not it's the glass half
full half empty no rich I'm just happy
to have a glass now that's what we call
the walk-off John darn boss I don't know
how often you're here in Los Angeles but
you have a you have a home here anytime
you damn well please man seriously
thanks I mean we all love you know thank
you all love when you come by here and
again you're your inspirational your
story you look great
thanks man you really do and you're at
the top of your game brother thanks and
watch America's Got Talent the champions
I'm an honor to be one of the top 50
acts in the world and let's rock and
roll man Monday at 8:00 Eastern Time
7:00 central on NBC good to see you John
thank you so Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience